hello
this is richard ladner from the
university of washington
and today i'm going to talk about
students with disabilities
in the united states i know there's
people from all over the world
that might be watching this and i
apologize that i can't cover every
country in the world
um but the united states might be
indicative of
what's happening in the rest of the
world
so i want to go back to president
obama's state of the union address in
he said in the coming years we should
build on that progress
by offering every student the hands-on
computer science and math classes
that make them job ready on day one
and i would add to that that makes them
ready to go to college
uh on day one for those that are capable
of doing so
and this is kind of the mantra for the
cs for all movement
in the united states it really started
more than ten years ago
um but it sort of got this name cs for
all
uh fairly recently maybe five years ago
um but the idea that the computer
science shouldn't just be for the elite
it shouldn't just be an ap course but
there should be courses for
for everyone and that would be everyone
including those with disabilities
so let's talk about disability in k
through 12.
so one group are those that are served
under the individuals with disabilities
education act
commonly called idea so under that
program a student would have an
individualized education
program and iep and an iep would sort of
set the educational goals for the
student
as well as any accommodations the
student might need to succeed
in school it might say that a student
really isn't capable
of doing computer science and should be
doing something else
now in the united states there's about
7.1 million students
in 2018 or 14 of the 50 million
students in the united states that are
k-12 public education
so that's one group 7.1 million second
group are those under section 504 of the
rehabilitation act
those students don't have a different
education plan
what they do is they have provisions or
accommodations
and by my estimate and it's hard to find
real numbers it's about 2 million more
students
in the united states so that would be
9.1 million students
or about 18 so
that's a big number 18 that's almost one
out of five students
have a disability or recognized
disability in the united states and k
k-12
education so just to give you an idea
i have the data for washington state
there's about 1.14 million students in
k-12
education in washington state in public
education
and about almost 15 are under idea
and actually 4.2 percent are under
section 504
so there we're approaching you know 20
percent
so 19.1 percent
so if we look at just idea there are
some demographics from
the national center for education states
statistics
um the total remember was 7.1 million
and of that group about 2.4 million
have a learning disability 1.4
million have speech or language
disability
1 million about health and 700
000 um are on the autism spectrum
and i should mention this autism number
760 000
is about twice as much as it was like
say about
five or six years ago so that's growing
that number is actually growing
and then there's other groups now um at
the very bottom here are some
smaller groups those that are deaf or
hard of hearing
those that have mobility issues perhaps
can't use a mouse and a keyboard
um and those that have vision
disabilities maybe use a screen reader
or some other
access device now those are very small
groups but they
should be included as well and i should
say a little bit more about those groups
that they're the ones that
principally use a lot of technology
while the
groups above uh it's more pedagogy and
universal design for learning and things
like that
so interestingly in 2020
the state of computer science education
came out just actually about a month ago
illuminating disparities and this is put
out by the
code.org advocacy coalition of the
computer science teachers association
and the expanding computer education
pathways
organization and for the first time
they've had data
on disabilities taking computer science
in the united states
11 states reported in those 11 states
12.9
of students are under idea
and it turned out that 7.6
of the students taking computer science
are also under idea
so as you can see there's a gap now you
can imagine that this gap
could be well students that aren't
capable intellectually capable
of taking computer science they have a
severe disability
intellectual disability for example but
that group
actually is fairly small and i don't
have exact data on this but my feeling
is that 85 to 90
of students under idea are capable of
taking computer science
so there is still a gap
now disability in higher ed is a another
story
there's no idea just section 504
so all students at higher ed have the
same educational objectives
you can't really change them but what
you can provide or accommodations
under section 504 of the real
rehabilitation act
so students with documented disabilities
can request accommodations through
the office of disability resources for
students
and that's the name at the university of
washington but other universities have
different names for these for these
offices
and universities are required to provide
those accommodations
so the actual number of students under
section 504 in higher education is
unknown
i don't know that number i wish i did
so there's also the national center for
education statistics
which has sampling data from higher
education
and it's very interesting to see the
changes over time
so in 2011 2012
uh 11.1 percent of undergraduates have a
disability
by sampling and 5.3 of graduate students
have a disability
so that seems like a fairly reasonable
number but what happened
in between uh 2015 and 17
that number grew from 11.1
to 19.4 percent of undergraduates have a
disability
this is more than the number of students
under idea
under you know high school students say
and 11.9 of graduate students have a
disability
now you know in my estimation you know
the number can't change something
must have changed what what happened
between 2011
and 2015.
no i don't believe the percentage of
students with disabilities
did not essentially double in a few
years
so what happened is the survey questions
about disability
changed and i don't know the exact
difference
of that nces used in these surveys
but i do know the different questions at
another level
so how did this change well there was an
interagency committee
in the united states agreed uh in the
past 10 years to change the definition
of disability before it was based on an
individual's condition were they blind
were they deaf
did they have cerebral palsy whatever
the condition is
now it's based on the impact of an
individual's functional
abilities so instead of asking are you
blind or visually impaired
they might ask is your vision
you know do you have a vision difficulty
that's
moderate severe or you can't see it all
that's the kind of question that they
have now and so it's a little ambiguous
since they don't use the word disability
anymore
they try to say what's the impact and
i think that's the reason the these
numbers increased
so let's look at this one i studied a
lot more the survey of earned doctorates
so every
student who earns a doctorate in the
united states
fills out a survey and they do ask
demographic questions
about disability so in 2010 2011 it was
about three percent of doctorates
were disabled and this number about
three percent
uh was stable for a couple of years and
before that actually it was
stable at about 1.5 to 2 so it actually
grew
in a couple of years so what happened
in 2018-19 is that number 3.0 jumped to
7.5
of docker doctorates were disabled so
more than more than doubled
so this is another enigma why did this
happen and here i have the
the reasons so the survey of earned
doctorates in 2010-2011
asked the following question on c10
do you have the following disabilities
mark yes or no for each one and there
they ask
you blind or visually impaired you can
answer yes or no deaf or hard of hearing
physical or orthopedic disability
learning or cognitive disability vocal
or speech disability
or other which you can specify
so there they were talking about the
condition
again and so that seemed to make sense
to some degree
but then they changed it in 2018 2019 or
actually before that um
so now it's a more complicated question
and it doesn't ask about disability
it says the following several questions
are designed
to help us better understand the
educational paths of individuals with
specific
functional limitations what is the usual
degree
of difficulty you have with
and then there were five categories and
i'm only going to cover the first
category because there's so many of them
and so they ask seen do you have
difficulty seeing
words or letters in ordinary newsprint
with your glasses contact lenses if you
usually wear them
and then you can answer no problem
slight moderate
severe or unable to do
so if you marked three four or five
moderate severe or unable to do you were
classified as having a disability
so actually the number of people that
said they were
blind or visually impaired or having the
same difficulty
rose from much less than one percent to
three percent so three percent of all
doctors
have a vision disability which is a very
very large number
now i want to give some credit to the
competing research association
data buddies project because they do ask
about disability
and this is a survey i really like i
think it has some interesting results
and that's how i feel like an outsider
in the computer science as a computer
science major
and they asked almost 10 000 computer
science undergraduate
computer science majors of which 7.9
reported having a disability so it's
self-reported
and that number 7.9 seems somewhat
reasonable
so that's 755. and then when we look
at the categories here on the left we'll
just point out all
students with disabilities felt 32
percent of them
one-third of them felt like an outsider
that's not so good
if you look at the very bottom majority
men without disabilities was 17
so that's close to doubling now if you
had something in addition
for example if you were a woman at the
very top there if you're a woman with a
disability
um it would be you would feel like an
outsider
about 46 of the time and it's almost the
same number for
an underrepresented minority with a
disability so disability
just being having a disability or
feeling you have a disability
inhibits you from feeling comfortable as
a computer science major
and this this was done just a few years
ago in 2018.
so there's the women at the top
so let's look at industry so the only
thing i found in industry is a 2020
stack over release
stack overflow survey and stack overflow
is a
is a question of answer system for
program
programmers and developers so that they
can get their technical questions
answered and for this survey and there's
there's hundreds of thousands of people
that
use a stack overflow maybe millions
and they're all computer scientists
basically
so for the 2020 survey there were
about 64 500 respondents
and of that group um 14.8 percent
reported
anxiety mood emotional disorder or
autism
so that's about 15 so that's a pretty
big number so maybe
you know computer fields cause a lot of
unusual anxiety
or mood problems i don't know
and then another two percent this
actually could overlap you could have a
physical difference and
an anxiety issue so two percent reported
a physical difference
blind or having seen difficulty being
deaf
or having a hearing difficulty so this
survey is the only survey i know
of sort of computer professionals that's
out there
so in summary data on disability is
ambiguous
is it a documented disability like you
have to have in k-12
who documents it is itself reported
what is the question asked and you can
get very different numbers
depending on the question asked a
disability definition is unsettled
is it a condition is it a functional
limitation
what is the level of difficulty if it's
a function limitation how is that
defined
and finally you know disability turns
out to be kind of like an identity
that somebody who has a disability might
identify i
i'm blind i'm deaf or whatever
um and so maybe identity is a better way
to think about
disability so my take on everything is
that disability is part of the diversity
of life it's there
it's around the world about one seventh
of the world's population
uh is said to have a disability
according to the world
health organization it's it's common
diversity is good for computer science
because different perspectives and
skills
lead to better products and services and
so we want these people with
disabilities to get into our field
and make innovations
thank you very much
now